[Musique]
c'était le président
ukrainien monsieur Zelinski convaincu
d'une victoire de l'Ukraine cette année
en 2023 est-ce qu'il a raison est-ce que
c'est possible on vous propose trois
regards à notre panel ce soir celui de
Henri Paul Normandin ancien ambassadeur
du Canada à l'ONU ancien diplôme du
Canada en Chine aussi pierre Saint-Cyr
colonel à la retraite des Forces armées
canadiennes ancienne attachée de défense
aux ambassades du Canada et à Moscou
ainsi qu'à keV et Raphaël Jacob notre
expert en politique américaine chercheur
associé de l'Observatoire sur les
États-Unis à la chair à zura je vous
salue tous les trois bonsoir bonsoir
alors commençons avec ce que dit
aujourd'hui monsieur Zelinski en cette
date anniversaire première année de
guerre en Ukraine il est porteur
aujourd'hui d'un message empreint
d'espoir et de détermination il dit
l'Ukraine va gagner en 2023 il dit même
c'est une victoire qui est inévitable
cette année contre la Russie est-ce que
c'est possible monsieur Saint-Cyr votre
regard de militaire vous dit quoi
par contre il y a deux facteurs assez
importants pour concrétiser une telle
victoire c'est la rapidité des
équipements occidentaux qui lui sont
envoyés et aussi le nombre de ces
équipements faut que ça soit arrivé dans
un temps propice et ça pourrait être
énormément faudrait que ça soit envoyé
ce printemps pour que éventuellement si
un offensive de russe qui se fait dès
que le terrain permet parce que on
l'hiver c'est à sa fin mais après
l'hiver c'est quand même des conditions
marées causes sont venus
pour les véhicules blindés qui ne
pourront pas circuler aussi facilement
mais dès que tout que le sol ne
permettra éventuellement les Russes
pourrai faire un offensive il faudrait
que les Ukrainiens soient prêts à les à
les arrêter et si les arrêtent bien mais
il pourrait reprendre eux leur
contre-offensive et espérer une victoire
éventuellement j'ai entendu beaucoup de
si votre réponse on va aller voir
Monsieur Normandin ce qu'il en pense
monsieur Normandin le Canada aujourd'hui
annonce qu'il ajoute 4 chars léopard à
sa livraison pour un total de 8
finalement de la part du Canada la
Pologne a dit aujourd'hui qu'il y a déjà
des chars qu'elle donne qui viennent
d'arriver et ils sont prêts à faire plus
ils sont prêts même à former des pilotes
Ukrainiens si jamais un jour un pays le
raccorde la faveur de leur donner des
avions des F16 américains c'est ce que
Monsieur zelinsky aimerait bien avoir
mais il n'y a toujours pas accès
pensez-vous effectivement plus graines
peut gagner cette année
évidemment c'est difficile à plaisir le
président zency évidemment se doit de
projeter la confiance et il a certaines
cartes dans son jus dont évidemment
l'appui des pays des pays occidentaux
notamment au niveau du matériel
militaire mais on se pose toujours des
questions sur la capacité de la Russie
de soutenir évidemment cette opération
militaire là alors c'est un peu
difficile à prédire ceci dit il faut
espérer que la Chine
ne se mêle pas directement dans le
conflit et qu'elle ne fournissent pas
d'armes à la Russie parce que si jamais
on devait en venir si jamais on en
venait là ça je pense que ça pourrait
changer la donne mais pour l'instant en
tout cas la Chine n'a pas franchi cette
ligne rouge et on espère que ça va
demeurer ici on va parler dans un tout
petit instant du rôle de la Chine qui se
propose comme les médiateurs mais on
verra jusqu'à quel point c'est sérieux
mais d'abord Raphaël j'aimerais vous
entendre aussi est-ce que c'est possible
une victoire cette année de l'Ukraine en
fait Julie avant de répondre à la
question je proposerai moi-même une
question en prenant peut-être un ou deux
ou 25 pas de recul qu'est-ce qu'on veut
dire par victoire quelle bonne question
parce que écoutez si on se fie au
gouvernement ukrainien aux dernières
nouvelles la victoire c'est défini non
seulement comme le fait de renvoyer les
Russes en totalité à la maison mais de
reprendre la totalité des territoires
qui ont été annexés officiellement l'an
dernier par le dîner évidemment dans
l'Est dans le sud-est du pays dans le
dombasque mais c'est également de
reprendre la Crimée la Russie aura vie
ou à prix tout au moins officiellement
du côté du Kremlin il y a maintenant
presque exactement 9 ans si c'est ce
qu'on vise et c'est ce qu'on définit
comme étant victoire je dirais oui
j'imagine que c'est possible mais il
faudra pas nécessairement miser beaucoup
d'argent dans le court terme ça c'est
une chose la deuxième chose c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire aussi comme
victoire à plus long terme parce que il
y a éventuellement espérons là
espérons-le la fin des hostilités à
proprement dit en termes de conflit
chaud de conflits ouvertement armés en
même temps
on peut une fois et encore une fois là
je me projette plus loin dans le temps
mais une prise max ça se produit
éventuellement est-ce qu'on peut et
comment est-ce qu'on peut plancher sur
une situation une dynamique qui va être
stable et qui va être réellement
pacifique avec les populations
majoritairement russophone à l'intérieur
de l'écran il va y avoir ça aussi à
considérer comme comme dynamique qui est
vraiment pas évident donc autrement dit
là une paix durable et réellement stable
et saine dans le court terme c'est ce
qu'on veut dire par victoire
malheureusement tragiquement d'abord
avant tout pour la population
ukrainienne j'ai beaucoup
personnellement de misère en voir
parlons du rôle de la Chine alors la
Chine s'est proposée cette semaine comme
étant une sorte de médiateur elle l'a
dit à Moscou elle le dit maintenant
monsieur Zelinski elle a une sorte de
proposition moi je vais l'appeler accord
de paix la Chine n'utilise pas ce
vocabulaire mais on comprend que c'est
un peu le message elle dit qu'elle veut
le faire dans le respect de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Ukraine et des
revendications sécuritaires
russes alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
exactement monsieur Normandin
vous savez quand on a commencé à parler
de cette proposition de la Chine qui
s'en venait moi mes attentes n'étaient
pas très élevées par rapport à ça et
quand j'ai lu la proposition ce matin
effectivement et il y a pas beaucoup de
choses utiles dans tout ça tout d'abord
il faut regarder la nature du document
en fait ce n'est pas vraiment une
proposition de règlement du conflit il
n'y a rien quand au contenu qui qui
prescrit certaines solutions il y a même
rien quant au processus à suivre ce
n'est qu'une liste en 12 points de
grands principes et d'idées et ça se
limite à peu près à ça maintenant si on
regarde un peu plus près il y a quand
même deux trois éléments d'intérêt
là-dedans tout d'abord la première ligne
du document affirme le principe de la
souveraineté des États et puis ensuite
on parle de l'intégrité territoriale et
tout mais bon par la suite il y a rien
qu'on demande à la Russie eu égard à la
souveraineté des États alors c'est un
peu c'est un peu vite de sens et puis en
fait lâcher dans l'appel à des processus
de négociation un règlement pacifique et
tout c'est bien beau des grands encore
rien de concret et surtout la Chine fait
référence à cesser le feu or c'est le
feu dans les conditions actuelles ça
servirait évidemment à renforcer les
positions de la de la Russie et son
occupe territoire ceci dit s'il y a une
chose je pense qui est important qui est
pertinente dans ce document là c'est que
la Chine réaffirme sans équivoque son
opposition à l'utilisation de l'arme
nucléaire alors ça je pense que c'est
c'est important c'est déjà un message
fort ici Monsieur Saint-Cyr la Russie a
déjà réagi à cette proposition de la
Chine elle tique beaucoup sur l'idée de
l'intégrité du territoire de l'Ukraine
elle dit un instant moi je veux qu'on
reconnaisse que j'ai déjà un excès on va
regarder une casse qu'elle a un accès
bien évidemment il y a l'acrymé depuis
2014 mais rappelons-nous que il y a
quelques mois il y a eu des référendums
aussi sur quatre territoires donc ce
sont des territoires que la Russie
revendiquent aujourd'hui elle n'est pas
prête à les céder même si par exemple si
on s'engageait cette semaine dans une
négociation de paix je veux dire le
noeud du problème ça risque d'être ce
territoire justement
et puis les Ukrainiens n'accepteront
jamais
ces termes-là ce que la chaîne propose
dans ces 12 points et puis je me suis
Normandin il a clairement mentionné
c'est pas clair c'est vague ça ressemble
beaucoup à un accord que j'appellerais
un Minsk 3 qui voudrait imposer encore
et l'Ukraine et l'Ukraine n'acceptera
jamais de tes conditions parce que les
accords de Minecraft 1 et 2 n'ont pas
été respectées il n'était pas
respectable non plus ce qui a conduit
au conflit que perdurer dans le temps de
basse maintenant si on veut ramener de
telles conditions pour établir une paix
comme le comme les Chinois l'est
sous-entendre dans leurs documents les
Ukrainiens accepteront jamais
lui a dit qu'il était prêt à entendre la
Chine il juge nécessaire d'utile de
travailler avec Pékin Raphaël qu'est-ce
que vous décodez là-dedans je déconne
d'abord avant tout Julie qu'il faut
peut-être essayer de mettre les mites de
côté là une fois pour toute 12 mois
après le début de ce conflit là la Chine
n'est pas un médiateur dans le sens
neutre du terme ce n'est pas vrai que
c'est un pays qui est complètement entre
les deux et qui a aucun espèce d'intérêt
là-dedans c'est personnellement je n'en
reviens presque pas qu'il y en a encore
évidemment je vous invite pas là-dedans
qui qui croit il semble vouloir répéter
ce métier ce n'est pas le cas d'autant
toujours la rappeler qu'au tout début en
fait avant même le conflit à peu près
trois semaines avant officiellement le
premier soldat russe traverse la
frontière ukrainienne chez jumping et
Vladimir Poutine ont émis un communiqué
conjoint dans lequel on annonçait
pratiquement avec fierté en fait avec
fierté qu'on avait désormais un
partenariat sans limite entre la Russie
et la Chine ça c'est une chose de deux
la chaîne
la Chine a apporté un certain un appui
clair sur le plan diplomatique à la
Russie a apporté un certain appui
économique et même un certain appui
matérielles sans pour autant fournir des
armes elle a fait tout ça envers la
Russie elle n'a pas fait ça envers du
crâne alors ça ça n'en dit déjà beaucoup
et les réactions aujourd'hui est
intéressante l'ambassadeur russe au
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
aujourd'hui a dit ben nous on est prête
à faire une certaine référence à la
proposition de la Chine mais il a dit
nous on est prête à négocier sur la base
des objectifs de notre opération
spéciale militaire alors ça n'en dit
beaucoup et puis du côté de l'Ukraine en
fait c'est qu'on demeure poli face à la
Chine on tente d'une certaine façon de
s'assurer que la Chine n'est pas trop
contre nous alors c'est pour ça que la
réaction la réaction je pense
ukrainienne est un peu un peu mitigé
voilà tout à fait c'est prudent de la
part de l'Ukraine je pense bon alors on
a regardé le scénario est-ce que
l'Ukraine peut gagner cette année on a
regardé le rôle de la Chine avec sa
proposition regardons le pire des
scénarios maintenant si l'Ukraine ne
l'emporte pas effectivement cette année
est-ce que la guerre pourrait durer plus
qu'un an est-ce que ça pourrait durer
longtemps monsieur Saint-Cyr
oui ça peut être une guerre d'usure je
pourrais s'installer définitivement
puisque les deux côtés vont savoir quand
même des armes et vont être en mesure de
ce bombarder mutuellement la seule
limite qui vont avoir peut-être que côté
humain ou éventuellement les forces sont
présents sont diminuées et diminué mais
on peut mais ça peut prendre encore
beaucoup beaucoup de temps il peut y
avoir une guerre d'usure d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'on pense qui va venir de
plus en plus parce que les Russes ont
utilisé comme les conditions
mathématiques que je mentionnais un
petit peu plus tôt les Russes ont
utilisé de plus en plus d'artillerie
pour pour défaire les dépositions
ukrainiennes donc ils vont peut-être
protéger à ce moment-là leur potentiel
humain pour éventuellement faire des
opérations plus tard dans l'année ou des
offensives plus tard dans la la saison
alors ça peut s'amener ça définitivement
une guerre qui peut durer beaucoup de
mois encore sinon peut-être une année et
plus et là ça amène un autre impact ici
c'est-à-dire une certaine lassitude de
la part des partenaires qui appuient
actuellement l'Ukraine donc les pays
occidentaux avec les États-Unis en tête
de liste Raphaël si ça dure trop
longtemps vous l'avez dit ça coûte une
fortune aux États-Unis appuyer l'Ukraine
on risque de se lasser ou on risque de
trouver de l'opposition à l'interne aux
États-Unis avant d'aller rapidement pour
faire quoi parce que Monsieur
Saint-Sever de mentionner je pense qu'il
faut réaliser à quel point de part et
d'autre on le conçoit et on le voit très
clairement du côté occidental à quel
point c'est perçu c'est vu et c'est vécu
comme une guerre de nécessité si on veut
une guerre défensive de la part de
l'Ukraine je pense qu'il faut réaliser
du côté russe du côté de Monsieur
Poutine qui les raisons sur le fond au
nom je voudrais que c'est une autre une
autre question mais c'est également vu
et vécu comme une guerre défensive quand
on écoute le discours encore de Monsieur
Poutine cette semaine celui qui l'a
livré au c'est le discours d'un homme
qui se sent et qui se voit comme étant
carrément assailli par les Occidentaux
donc tant est aussi longtemps qu'on va
avoir l'impression de part et d'autre
qu'on est carrément dans un dans une
lutte existentielle pour notre surview
dans lequel monsieur Poutine pour la
survie de son régime et qu'on avance si
peu de façon durable d'un point de vue
militaire donc les gains qui sont faits
sont somme toute assez modestes de part
et d'autre on s'échange de balle c'est
je crois encore une fois très difficile
de ce côté une fin à court terme ça
c'est une chose pour ce qui est de
l'appui américain personnellement
jusqu'à quel point en fait juste à quel
point combien de temps que Monsieur
Biden dans la dynamique actuelle tout au
moins là du conflit va être à la maison
blanche lui et son équipe je serai
personnellement très surpris que l'aide
américain l'après américain soit
foncièrement remis en question en même
temps monsieur Baden sera pas
nécessairement là pour toujours dans la
mesure où on a une élection
présidentielle aux États-Unis l'an
prochain et quand vous regardez déjà les
contours des primaires républicaines qui
se dessine cette aides-là pour être très
sérieusement
si ça dure longtemps mais dans le sens
trop longtemps c'est à dire qu'avec des
pays qui commencent à remettre en
question leur appui parce que c'est une
voix qu'on entend on n'est pas
majoritaire mais on l'entend quand même
il y a des gens qui disent un jour il va
falloir qu'ils s'assoient un jour il va
falloir négocier jusqu'à quel point
négocier est-ce que est-ce que c'est
possible d'envisager une négociation
avec une Ukraine qui se demeure intacte
avec l'ensemble de son territoire ou
est-ce qu'un jour ou l'autre si on en
arrive avec ce scénario elle devra céder
des portions sont territoire
ça va être difficile et ultimement
évidemment ce sera ça aux écoles aux
Ukrainiens eux-mêmes a décidé quelle
position est bonne mais je peux pas
m'empêcher de souligner que c'est très
difficile de négocier avec quelqu'un
comme une qui vit dans un univers un peu
dans un univers un peu un peu parallèle
alors je crains bien effectivement que
on risque de de sans liser encore pour
un bon moment parce qu'au moment où on
se parle je pense qu'il y a pas beaucoup
de monde qui voit une issue quelconque
qui vont lui aussi quelconque au conflit
alors on voit que tous les scénarios
sont sur la table les pires et les
meilleurs aussi on connaît pas l'avenir
personne tout ce qu'on sait c'est qu'on
vient de franchir une première année et
que les Ukrainiens restent extrêmement
déterminé et les pays alliés comme le
nôtre encore très motivé on verra
combien de temps ça dure merci pour ces
regards croisés messieurs bonne soirée
merci